let me start by saying congrats on the
movie mmm it was [ __ ] awesome and two
hours back in this world you know what I
mean I have to start I think with at any
point even though Vince is a genius yeah
like he's a god genius but it's a god
you're right look at any point though
were you saying to him you know the
finale is kind of amazing do we want to
play with this at all or we sort of like
he's gonna get this I had no doubt in my
mind that he would nail it no doubt and
I'm with you I think it is so hard to
nail a landing
when ending a series especially a very
popular one like breaking bad because
everyone is so connected and passionate
about it but they also don't want to say
goodbye and they're like if you're gonna
say goodbye you better [ __ ] do it
perfectly and I think Vince and the
writers really nail the landing and I
think some people are like whoa whoa
whoa don't mess with this legacy here
but I you know the only thing I could
say to that is look you trusted Vince
through the the duration of Breaking Bad
that trust should continue well also
Bret the better call Saul was vent how
also of course so he's doing an
incredible job there and he doesn't need
to tell this story you know but it was
just something that was in him he's like
ha I want to know what happened to Jesse
I mean he wanted to know sure no he
wanted to know and that was the one sort
of question that he kept getting asked
that I kept getting asked what happened
to Jesse and so um here we are so uh how
honestly how early on did you know this
movie was going to happen and how long
did you have to keep it a secret I got a
phone call two and a half years ago
maybe
that Vince had an idea he said look I
have this idea I wanted to see if you
were on board before I dove deeper I
don't want to put the cart before the
horse because I don't want to do it
unless it's perfect but I want to see if
you're on board and then I'll go from
there and I said Vince I'd follow you
into a fire whatever you want to do and
then he's like all right well I'll get
back to you and then cut to five six
seven months later roughly he said it's
done and I think it's pretty perfect
I can't imagine so now that it's been
out now that the movies made and
everything you can talk freely so who'd
you tell back then that Vince might do
the movie well my wife was waiting
inside the store evolution in New York I
was talking to Ben's outside and I ran
inside I go babe you would have no idea
what this conversation was all about
because it was a scheduled call and
Vince wants to do a film that follows
Jesse Post Breaking Bad and we just kind
of sat there in silence because I didn't
like I knew it was gonna be genius of
course and what a fun thing to do you
know Vince had never directed a film
before and the fact that him and I were
able to go on that journey together as a
is a dream come true I told my family I
knew I could trust them they were very
excited and I just told a couple just a
couple best friends that's it and then
everybody else had just lied to right
exactly I'm not talking to Vince for the
movie so I am curious though did were
there a lot of deleted scenes in the
movie do you remember or is it very
close to what you shot you know what
about about 30% of the movie was cut
really yeah the original cut was about
third three hours yeah I know that's
what I said that's what I said to him
when I first saw it I was like ah
this is so beautiful but where's the
other part of the movie you know and
he's I don't want to bore people I go
Vince people want more like more is more
in this situation so maybe down the road
there will be a you know another another
cut but with that said I think what what
we have is is is great it's great I'm I
literally my heart hurts you don't know
there's another cut out there so maybe
you know I can convince him to release
it well I'm gonna just do one follow-up
cuz I know Vince is gonna not want you
to tell too much but was there was there
a whole storyline that was taken out or
was it just scenes along the way no it
was just kind of shoe leather just kind
of scenes along the way on some scenes
were condensed there was a pretty
serious thing that was cut that was
actually the very first thing that Vince
wrote when he was writing this film was
the very first thing but he decided to
and it wasn't the first part of the
movie it was just the first thing that
he wrote but he decided to cut it I
won't tell you what that was but maybe
off-camera but yeah I was sad we
actually didn't even end up shooting it
it was just cut from the from the script
yeah that [ __ ] happens all the time
listen I I get a Kingdom of Heaven was
three hours and brought down to 220
there's so many things but I would like
to think that with Netflix maybe if the
film they could do an extended cut yeah
I mean they you know there's a lot of
stuff that was that landed on on film so
and and a cut that I actually never even
saw the initial cut the three-hour long
cut but you know come on Vince